this
is a reenactment come on in so the new
iphone 7 is water resistant and it's
something that i never tested so i
clearly unintentionally have tested it
so this is
the whole story of what happened i
walked in wasn't even going to the
bathroom and thankfully
the bathroom had just been cleaned so
we've got a freshly cleaned toilet right
there
i walk in i'm texting my sister and our
friend adam and something funny was
happening and i'm like this
i'm giggling i'm laughing at the text
and i go to
pick up this brush brush my hair i just
gotten out of the shower flip my hair
like this
to brush it and that is when the phone
just flies
right into the toilet but i step into
action i dive into this toilet
show us how you dive into the toilet no
no i was like no
and then i go in after and i fish it out
and then i'm like
[Music]
show us what happened in the pot you had
to go i was i was all the way in
i was all the way in turn on the water
get the soap i open it up i start
dumping the soap on it i am scrubbing
the phone
i rip off the white case throw it in the
toilet
and either go in the toilet oh the trash
can
oh god show us how you got it out of the
pot
jenna i went in like this i went in two
hands
yes two hands i went in did you
go in i went in it was okay i don't want
to touch it but
like i was like this don't you dare
don't you
dare stop it that's not funny tickle
tickle i went in
i went in so you went in i did and then
i scrub it off
i'm scrubbing i'm scrubbing my hands i'm
scrubbing my body and then i go and get
this contraption
phone so phone my mom got me this for
christmas so i dry it off it's all nice
and dry
shaking it getting all the excess water
stick it in the phone so
i let it sit for 10 minutes
i think about everything i think about
all the times that i've broken my phones
and and how i don't deserve a phone
are you making fun of my decor
no please update the albums okay
they're good albums except for the drake
one oh
just kidding just kidding it's a joke
where was i in my story phone soap
after 10 minutes this has uv lights in
it if you can see right here
well you can't because it only works
when it's closed but
so i take it out after 10 minutes i let
it air itself out
put a new case back on and then i tweet
about it and that's it and this is the
phone and it works perfectly
there's absolutely nothing wrong with it
the speakers sound incredible
oh
traffic sucks but yeah everything works
perfectly fine so there is no bad news
everything works perfectly
and i'm pretty impressed how resilient
it was
to jump back from its its little swim
anyway
my phone works i'm happy here it is it's
clean and i think i'm going to put this
in for an extra 10 minutes
just for all safety purposes
thanks for watching i'm gonna try to
take better care of my things
no just kidding
now that that story's out of the way
let's carry on with the rest of this
[Music]
vlog
hi you see this camera you know i'm
definitely going to be doing something
to publicly
embarrass myself
[Music]
so if you're new to my channel i used to
do a lot of very strange and weird
things
and those were probably some of my most
favorite things that i've ever posted
just like
so seriously you're not piercing your
ear at least it's out it's so it's
exoskeleton i'm not sure if you guys
have done this here before
that no we haven't
[Music]
so last night my sister and i were
watching some old videos that we did and
i was laughing
so hard basically public embarrassment
was so fun for me
but why i bring this all up in this
camera specifically is because with this
it has such an incredible zoom it has
amazing image stabilization
so we always used to use one of these
camcorders when we would do that kind of
stuff so i've been using this camera
really just to do live streams anytime i
did anything live which is not very
frequently
but i have a little hdmi converter that
goes out to usb the hdmi goes into that
then that lets me be able to view what's
on here on my computer and do the live
stream
so the whole reason that i'm here
talking about this is because i'm
heading to sami's camera which is one of
my favorite places
to get a charger for these batteries
because i can't find the charger so
really that's it that's what we're doing
today
and hopefully later libby will make her
return
i've also been obsessed with this belkin
apple watch charger this was featured in
my little apple goodie bag review
i haven't used an actual apple watch
charger in so long i just use this
let's pack up started from the bottom
and you're still in a lobster costume
oh geez oh god i just yep you know i
can't get upset when i see people say
mean comments about me because if i
was a completely anonymous person and i
came across some of my videos
i'd probably be making the same
assumptions as some of those commenters
so i completely understand i get it that
doesn't mean you should still be mean
lobsters have hearts too
[Music]
this is actually one of the first places
that i ever brought maddie out into
public
we had come here i forget what we were
getting something from my drone
i believe they thought that the bag that
i had madigan was a camera bag and it
was so funny they're like oh some kind
of camera do you have i was like nope
this is a tiny puppy you love sammy's
do you like sammy's is this your
favorite place
[Music]
we decided to take maddie to the dog
park for a little bit and we're gonna go
get our nails done because you know what
what else do you do in la on a friday
when you need to get your nails done
basic but then after that oh are we
going to be going to the costume store
do you think
i thought we were going to go do some
more basic things like shopping
yeah but i think libby wants to go
shopping is what she told me
i think she's invited we'll see what
happens
jen where are we going i don't want to
talk about it
i just made a phone call and i said
hello do you guys have a lobster costume
and he's like
for adults i said yes i said i'll see
you in a minute
oh yes it looks good that's perfect
this is the life that we live he's
scared of it
let's see it's just me can you believe
this
friday night jen i can
i guess just get your headphones so that
you'll be able to monitor the audio this
thing is so wrinkled i look like a cheap
lobster bisque i'm so
nervous like when i do these things like
it was like oh you you've got such guts
i can't believe it i'm like no i get
really nervous to be honest with you
like i'm starting i'm like i i'm having
heart palpitations
oh jesus i'm so embarrassed already do i
look okay
like how's my first look
all right let's go that's what i look
like
we gotta get out of here
[Music]
all right there's nothing that i hate
more than mess i don't like clutter but
yet my entire life revolves around it
and i can't get away from it
no matter how hard i try i just cleaned
this downstairs the other day with jenna
we got rid of so many things and now
it's a complete disaster again
[Music]
huge box from mario my baby boy
look at you oh yes
belly bailey i just got done shooting a
bunch of videos
and i did a bunch of unboxing videos in
my kitchen because
it just works as a really good setup
when i'm doing
unboxings of things that are quite big
spoiler alert from a future video
some more spoilers from the empty boxes
it was just me shooting today sometimes
i like to shoot by myself because
i like to shoot at sort of like a
leisurely pace when i shoot with other
people i feel like i'm super rushed and
i'm just going and going and going and
going and trying to shoot as much as i
can
so far i shot three videos i have one
half of another one to finish up and
then i have one more to shoot upstairs
and then jenna's gonna come over and
we're gonna go shopping we were supposed
to go shopping
the other day in the libby video but
instead i ended up dressing up as a
lobster
and making a fool of myself which was
incredible
do you remember what happened here
yes i'll never forget we're back at the
scene of the crime
we were so excited to go shopping and
everything closes the day it's
8 30. everything's closed
[Music]
oh gosh the scene of the crime
there it is that's where we were
you